-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy- and Golden
Globe-nominated actress
you know from the "Divergent
films franchise
and the hit series
"Big Little Lies."
She stars in "The Last Lette
from Your Lover,"
which is streaming on Netfli
on July 23rd.
Let's take a look.
-Come. Mr. Booth, dance with me.
-Have fun, my friend.
-♪♪ Is slowly
going on the rocks now ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
♪♪ Tell me, tell me, baby
♪♪ Whatcha gonna do 'bout it
Whatcha gonna do 'bout it? ♪
♪♪ Oh, tell me ♪♪
-Please welcome back to the show
Shailene Woodley.
Hello, Shailene. How are you
-Hi. I'm so good. How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
I mean, we've talked in the past
about the fact
that you are not particularl
good with new technology,
and seeing you there in a film
that takes place in the '60s
that must have been one of
the many draws to the project.
-Yeah. The fact that there was
no cellphones and no laptops
was a major bonus.
It's so funny just watchin
that clip right now,
seeing, like, those dance move
and the music. It really just --
There's something
that was so transformative
about pretending
to live in that space
and that era where you actuall
had human connection.
You had two people
touching one another
instead of everything bein
through this 2-D screen.
-And it's interesting, you know,
it's also obviously
about letter writing.
And you are someone who
even in this modern day and ag
will write a letter.
Is this true?
-I love letters.
I love me some letters!
There's nothing better
than opening your mailbox
and putting a letter in
and having the anticipation of
"When's it going to get there?
What are they going to think
Are they going
to like what I wrote?"
And then also receiving them
I just --
I'm a hopeless romantic,
and there's something that's
just very, very romantic to me
about letter writing.
-I think I have two friend
who to this day
will still write
a handwritten thank-you letter
And they're like
the only two friends
that I want to be at my funeral,
'cause they're the only ones
that were nice enough
to take the time.
-[ Laughs ]
I think that's what it is.
When somebody writes me
even an e-mail --
I know that's not
a handwritten letter,
but when someone takes the tim
to write something out,
write their feelings out
and express what they're
experiencing in life,
it just hits a different part of
my core than, "Hey, how are you?
Ha, ha. Did you see
that game last night?"
-I think as long
as they spell it Y-O-U
instead of just
a solitary "U" --
-I can't. I cannot.
Thank goodness --
Do you remember
when texting first started
and it was like "TTYL," "BRB"?
"LOL" is still a thing,
but those ones -- Whew!
-Well, the heartbreaking
thing now is
there are just new ones
that I would have no idea.
I think the saddest thing
is when I google,
"What do these letters mean?
-It's so true.
-You know, obviously this is -
This show is about --
This film, I should say, i
about romance. Did you have --
Were there romantic films that
you were drawn to growing up
Do you have favorites?
-So many. I didn't really --
We didn't watch a lot of T
when I was growing up.
But my mom, whenever
she'd be folding laundry
or doing the dishes
or some sort of benign task,
she always had "Pretty Woman
or "Dirty Dancing"
or "Romancing the Stone"
or "Notting Hill" on.
And so those were kind of
the movies that I was raised on.
That was my filmography
when I was a child.
-Yeah, I just watched --
My wife made me watch "Notting
Hill" for the first time.
I had somehow missed it,
and just an A-plus.
It really holds up
incredibly well.
-It's so good, right?
-Yeah.
-Oh, it's just so --
It never gets old.
The music, it's so --
The cast. It's perfect.
-You also -- Speaking
of romance, you managed to do,
on a year where so many
relationships ended
during a pandemic,
you managed to start one.
Congratulations
on your engagement.
-Thank you so much.
Thank you. Yeah, I always laug
with my friends.
I'm like, "Y'all either
got divorced, engaged,
married, or had a baby."
Like, that summed up everyone'
quarantine experience.
[ Laughs ]
-You -- Now, I've been
fortunate enough
to meet Aaron Rodgers
a few times.
And I, of course, have read that
you are not a giant sports fan
I know that he is not someon
who is only
interested in sports.
He has a giant
breadth of interests.
But have you felt the need
to sort of bone up a little bi
on your sports terminology
-I mean, I guess I haven't fel
any pressure to,
but it's exciting, you know,
to get behind --
The Packers games are the only
ones I find really interesting
'cause I have people
to actually root for.
But it is a whole new world,
learning all of the different --
I still am always like,
"Oh, you scored a goal!"
He's like, "It's a touchdown."
Or I'll be like,
"You crossed the line,"
and he's like, "It's a yard,
or whatever.
I still can't --
I still can't get it right
but I'm learning,
slowly but surely.
-I just like that there's
something passive-aggressive
about saying,
"You crossed the line."
that he'd be like,
"Is this about the game
or something I did last night?
[ Both laugh ]
He sort of -- His --
Great outside of, obviously,
an incredible season,
his pandemic accomplishmen
was hosting "Jeopardy!"
Assuming he took it a seriousl
as he takes game prep,
how much "Jeopardy!"
did you have to watch with him
-Luckily -- I mean,
I was filming in Montreal
when he was prepping
for "Jeopardy!" And so I -
And he was quarantining.
So I would go to work
at 8:00 a.m., 6:00 a.m.,
and he would start his Netflix
"Jeopardy!" binge.
And then when I would get home
at 8:00 or 9:00 p.m.,
he would still be
watching "Jeopardy!"
And I would open the trash can
and I would just see like
bunch of empty to-go container
and milkshake cups that he had
ordered on Uber Eats.
And I was like,
"You literally just Uber Eated
and watched 'Jeopardy!'
all day long today."
He's like,
"Yeah, look at my notes."
And he had stacks of notebooks
of notes that he took
and highlighted
and went back through.
It was actually really inspiring
to watch his steadfast
commitment
to learning every single par
of the "Jeopardy!" game.
And we did a lot of rehearsing
back and forth
where he would read some fak
things that he had created
and be like, "Was my tone right?
Was the connotation
of this right?
How is it all working?"
[ Chuckles ] It was fun.
-Well, the preparation paid off.
I want to ask you
about a story I read recently.
You know, obviously,
one of the fun parts
about being in show business
is you meet new co-stars,
you build new friendships.
So, sort of after
your acting career started
you were backpacking
around Europe,
and you had a co-star
who helped you and a friend ou
in a way that I don't thin
many co-stars could.
-Yeah, he really did.
He really -- He took --
We were backpacking
through Europe. I was 19.
And I had just worked
with George on --
George Clooney --
on "The Descendants."
And he was like, "If you happe
to go to Europe this summer,
hit me up.
I've got a place in Italy.
And I was like -- I remember
being in Italy with my frien
going, "Do you think, like -
Should I? Should I not?"
Like, he's kind of like my dad
in a weird way.
Like, he's just, like, you know,
given me so much life advice
and he's been there for me
through so much.
And she's like, "Yeah, why not?"
And so he was like, "Send me
your address. I'll send a car.
And I was like, "No, no, no,
we'll take a train.
It's so easy." And he was like
"Give me your
frickin' address, dude.
Like, I'll send you a car.
And I remember we, like,
came out of our hostel.
Like, we hadn't showered
in maybe five days.
We stunk. We had our big
backpacks and mud on our shoes
And we get to
this fancy Lincoln Town Car.
And then we get to his house
[ Chuckles ]
I remember that moment going
"He is the greatest human bein
of all time
for not, one, commenting
on our stench,
and, two, for taking us in
and being like,
'I'm going to bathe you.
I'm going to make sure you guys,
like, have a European experience
that's different
from the European experience
you've been having.'"
And it was just --
It was really magical in
all of the ways that it could be
for a 19-year-old seeing
the world for the first time
-Now, did you have to,
after that, stay at a hostel
for the rest of your trip?
'Cause that would --
I would assume that would be
the hardest part.
-Well, you know
what's actually incredible
I mean, he is
the most incredible man
I've ever met
in my life, period,
apart from I guess Aaron.
I guess I need to say that now
-Good late save, Shailene.
[ Laughter ]
-That's how that works, right?
But, you know,
he had to leave town early
and so he was like, "I got you
guys a hotel room down the way."
And I was like,
"Don't worry about it!
We'll just go onto our nex
vacation, our next destination."
He was like,
"No, go to the hotel."
So we show up to this hotel,
and it's like a five star --
I want to say it's Hotel -
I can't remember the name of it.
But it's in --
It's on Lake Como.
And it was the first time
my friend and I
had ever seen a menu like that
never slept in a bed like that
And it just --
His, like, generosity
and his thoughtfulness
was absolutely stunning.
And from there, we did go stay
in a really [bleep]
hostel again.
And, I mean, that's just par
of the fun of it, you know
The fact that
we were lucky enough
to have both sides of the
experiences at that age was --
I really think set us up
for the lives
and the perspectives
that we have now.
-I was really hoping
that was going to be
one of those famous
George Clooney pranks
where he booked the hotel
but didn't pay for any of it
[ Both laugh ]
-He was like, "Alright, girls,
now it's your turn."
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
Give our love to Aaron,
and hopefully next time, we'll
see you here in the studio
-I will. Have a great day, Seth.